Si on avait cette fameuse étude,
la caisse les premiers. Si on
avait les étude, serait un
débat. Bonsoir.
- (Ensemble) bonsoir.
- Beaucoup de spécialistes, des
architectes qui disent n'étaient
pas ça en hauteur, ça va
défigurer. Vous en dites quoi?
- C'est un dossier très
important, depuis toujours cette
copro de la comme avoir ici à
Montréal. Toutes les fois qu'on
parle de transport gueulait
toujours des discussions. On a
eu la même chose avec le métro,
la ligne bleue. On n'en a parlé,
on était presque arrivé à une
solution et on a changé d'idée
en cours de route. On a peur
d'avoir peur et on a peur de ne
pas choisir le bon projet. Il
faut se rappeler, c'est pourquoi
on a besoin d'un mode de
transport qui va jusque dans
l'est de Montréal. La région de
Lescar présente en superficie la
même superficie que la Ville de
Paris. On parle de 500 000 de
population. On a l'occasion
rêvée de pouvoir enfin relier
les deux solitudes: l'est et
l'ouest. On est prêt. La photo
nous montre, on nous dit que le
nouveau REM qui est prévu aura
une signature unique. Ne sera
pas celui dans l'ouest de
Montréal avec les pilons de
béton. Les artistes sont
capables de prévoir.
- Vous faites confiance au
processus et vous dîtes,
l'avantage c'est que ça avance
ce train. Le quai Fernandez, la
méfiance énorme de la caisse là-
dessus. Dans cette partie où
vous êtes, pour une fois que ça
avance?
- Je suis méfiant. N'est pas
juste une structure de béton,
une structure de béton avec par-
dessus une armature de poteaux
qui tenaient des cathéters.
Sacré dans la ville un schisme.
Ça crée une barrière là où ça
passe et il faut regarder René-
Lévesque en particulier entre le
pont Jacques-Cartier et le
centre-ville. Sa carte qui a
énormément de potentiel. Il ne
faut pas que le voir comme il
est, il faut le voir comme il
peut le devenir et ça peut être
un quartier fantastique.
D'ailleurs, il y a beaucoup de
projets qui vont naître ici à la
maison de Radio-Canada, pour un
quartier résidentiel. Il est de
nouveau quartier qui s'en
vienne, on peut réinventer. Si
beaucoup de gens utilisent le
Remme, on peut les mettre au
sol, réimplanter des arbres.
- S'il y a des études qui disent
que c'est vrai c'était trop
compliqué entre elles. Ça se
peut. Vous allez dire qu'on n'y
va quand même « au grand jamais,
pas d'aérien.
- Les paquets aériens ou
souterrains, c'est un mythe. Ce
n'est pas juste un projet
technologique, c'est un modèle
d'affaires. Modèle d'affaires
supposent membre d'une structure
partout que les services de
l'est de Montréal mais qui après
se rendre à Repentigny et qui va
se rendre au nord vers l'aval.
Ils ne veulent pas arrêter ce
projet pour cette raison. S'il
n'y avait pas cette raison, sans
réfléchir transport en commun à
Montréal, une requête en droit
ça prend tramway au sol.
- On réfléchit depuis 40 ans
puis il ne fait rien.
- Exactement. La beauté est
extrêmement sceptique quand j'ai
entendu parler du REM. Il tente
de le tester sur la rive sud. On
a une chance incroyable d'avoir
enfin un service de transport
pour les gens, les 500 000 qui
demeurent dans l'est qui ont
actuellement des voies
réservées, qui ont des tests
cyclables, qui ont des autobus.
On parle de Montréal. De Pointe-
aux-Trembles à Montréal ça prend
1h30. Je crois que pour trois
tronçons on peut remettre en
cause peut-être la façon dont ça
va être fait, mais on ne peut
pas pénaliser les 500 000
personnes de l'autre côté ont
aussi une navette pluviale qui
les amène au centre-ville. Je
pense pour 500 000 personnes,
ils sont en mesure et en droit
d'avoir les mêmes services pour
se rendre au centre-ville que
ceux qui vivent au centre-ville.
C'est pour ça qu'il ne faut pas
crucifier le projet tout de
suite. Attendons les études et
regardons comment on peut aller.
- Il ne s'agit pas d'empêcher
ces personnes d'avoir un
transport. La RTM et la STM tu
leur donnes de mêmes conditions
opérationnelles et vont produire
un projet de transport de la
même qualité.
- La ligne bleue, on leur a fait
confiance et on ne l'a pas
encore.
- Le gouvernement n'a pas fait
les fonds. Avec la fameuse taxe
de récupérer 10 % du projet en
taxant les abords des voies,
parce que c'est ça qui se fait
avec la caisse. Si on met les
mêmes conditions à la RTM
condamne à la caisse, ils vont
arriver avec un magnifique
projet.
- Reportons ça sur la campagne.
Est-ce que l'on est en train de
voir que Madame Plante est entre
de ce sceptique, M. Coderre dans
les très défenseurs. Est-ce que
c'est comme ça que ça va se
jouer?
- j'ose espérer que ça ne se
passe pas au niveau d'avoir des
votes ni d'un bord ni de
l'autre. Il faut se rappeler la
raison pour laquelle on peut le
faire. On a une occasion devant
nous, ça ne veut pas dire va
prendre n'importe quel projet,
les études qui s'en viennent. Je
vais beaucoup plus avec la
confiance de regardons ce qui se
passe. Il y a un comité qui
essaie de se passer. Temporelle
et la ligne bleue, au pied
arrivé avec le Remme qui a déjà
fait ses preuves. Je pense à ces
citoyens qui en ont besoin et à
cette moitié de la ville sont
desservies comme une seconde
zone. Il est des taxes, ont
droit au même service et ça leur
prend 1h30.
- Il y avait plein de projets,
on peut en parler 1000 ans.
C'est sûr qu'avec la caisse,
beaucoup ont l'impression qu'il
y a un côté  bulldozer.
- En gros, ce n'est pas ce qui
se passe qu'elle n'a pas les
mêmes enjeux. Quand tu rentres
dans la ville, quand tu rentres
dans la ville, il faut que tu
fasses attention. Je n'ai jamais
vu de ma carrière une firme
d'architectes se retirait d'un
projet parce qu'il dise c'est
impossible qu'il soit beau. On
parle de la firme qui a fait le
quartier national de Montréal.
- À cette époque là tout le
monde disait un bâtiment qui
n'est pas bot et quelques années
plus tard c'est finalement une
oeuvre d'art.
- Justement, ce bâtiment qui
recouvrait l'autoroute sont des
experts d'intégration urbaine.
Ils ont un contrat juste devant
les yeux et se disent non, notre
réputation est en jeu on sort de
la expert doive être écouté, les
experts en organisation n'aient
pas entendu beaucoup qui de ce
que c'est une bonne idée je
propose d'entendre le comité
d'accompagnement s'intégration
urbaine qui va avoir des choses
à dire.
- Prochaine étape c'est l'étude
qui a démontré à la caisse que